Being arrested is a terrifying and frightening
thing with all the horror stories about police
abuses of power and other prisoners being
absolutely dead-set on making your life miserable
in a variety of horrifying ways… at least
that’s what the movies have taught us.
As so often happens, the reality of being
arrested doesn’t generally reflect what’s
depicted on the big screen.
So what about the one phone call rule?
It turns out, “You get exactly one phone
call when arrested” is a useful, simple
plot element, and easier to explain to an
audience than, “being arrested is a legal
minefield where your rights can vary based
on a variety of factors.”
In reality, the number of phone calls you
can make varies from as many as you want to
zero, depending on the severity and location
of your crime and how you act when arrested.
Thanks to the sixth amendment, you are entitled
to legal counsel and, as clarified in the
Supreme Court ruling in Brewer v. Williams,
you are entitled to that counsel “at or
after the time that judicial proceedings have
been initiated… whether by formal charge,
preliminary hearing, indictment, information,
or arraignment.”
As Hollywood depicts, you are also perfectly
within your rights to keep your mouth shut,
though they don’t actually tend to get it
quite correct in the way it’s commonly portrayed.
The police only need to give you the Miranda
warning if they are conducting a custodial
interrogation and want the record of that
interrogation to be admissible in court.
Other than that, giving you the Miranda warning
isn’t necessary.
In fact, even if they don’t give you this
warning when they are about to perform a custodial
interrogation, they can still use what they
learn in their investigation.
It’s just that what you specifically said,
in this case, isn’t admissible in a criminal
trial.
But if they use this information to find other
evidence, that certainly is.
So, bottom line, contrary to what Hollywood
shows, don’t expect them to give you the
Miranda warning while they are cuffing you,
and certainly don’t think you now have a
get out of jail free card because they didn’t.
As you might expect, any lawyer worth anything
will tell you to exercise the right to shut
up, no matter if you are 100%, without a shadow
of a doubt perfectly innocent and plan on
being completely honest about it.
There is literally no benefit to you talking
to the police in this situation where you
find yourself being arrested or brought in
for questioning about something you allegedly
did.
(For more on this subject, check out this
phenomenal lecture from Professor James Duane
and Officer George Bruch, of the Virginia
Beach Police Department.
Officer Bruch even goes into some clever interrogation
methods used by the police to get people to
talk.
Needless to say, in these interrogations,
they are extreme experts at extracting information
that might incriminate you and you are in
a high stress situation.
You will lose every time.
And if innocent, you might even make it seem
you’re guilty unintentionally due to the
stress of the situation.
The police aren’t looking to get an innocent
person convicted, but they don’t know you
and if you’re in that situation, they very
likely don’t think you’re innocent to
begin with and are looking for even the smallest
hint of evidence to use to further the case
against you.)
Now, the fact that you’re entitled to speak
to a lawyer would suggest you’re allowed
to use the phone.
But not actually.
You don’t necessarily need to use the phone
yourself to get a lawyer.
Further, the dramatic scenes depicted in cinema
where you use your one phone call to contact
someone and they don’t pick up, and so you
don’t get another call, is also completely
bunk.
While there is some variation in laws from
state to state, in general the police can,
at their discretion, allow you to make any
number of calls to friends or family members,
or really anyone you want, to set your affairs
in order.
As with using the phone at all, these phone-calls
are (usually) a privilege offered by the police;
a privilege that can be revoked at any time
should you become violent or antagonistic,
or are simply wasting their time by not using
your phone call(s) for a legitimate reason.
But if you behave yourself and are using your
calls constructively, in general you’re
not going to have any trouble getting access
to a phone.
As mentioned, the laws vary from state to
state.
For example, in the state of Nevada (171.153
of the Nevada Revised Statutes),
Any person arrested has the right to make
a reasonable number of completed telephone
calls from the police station or other place
at which the person is booked immediately
after the person is booked and, except where
physically impossible, no later than 3 hours
after the arrest.
So in this case, unless the phone lines are
down or you become so violent that they end
up having to tase you to unconsciousness,
or similar scenarios, you’ll get a “reasonable
number” of phone calls regardless of how
much of a jerk you may be.
One would imagine that the better you behave,
though, the higher a “reasonable number”
will turn out to be.
However, this isn’t always the case in other
states where sometimes your only phone-related
right is potentially the ability to contact
a lawyer.
But, again, even if this is not a right, generally
if you need to call your boss at work to say
you’re not going to make it in, or contact
your husband to tell him where you’re at,
or you need to arrange for someone to pick
up your kids from school, etc. etc., most
police officers are happy to accommodate that
as long as you’re not causing problems.
Anecdotally, in researching this topic, I
even found one case where an officer was willing
to drive those arrested to an ATM so the people
could get money needed for posting bond.
His department did not take credit or debit
cards.
So when it’s that or waiting around for
the person to make the necessary phone calls
to gather together the cash and have someone
bring it in, at that particular department,
they just take you to an ATM if you’ve got
the necessary cash in your bank account.
It’s quicker and easier for them (and you).
Without them doing this, there are scenarios
where you might spend the whole weekend in
the county jail waiting for a judge to see
you, when you otherwise could have just made
bond and been out right away.
So what if you’re causing problems, but
still need to get a lawyer, notify someone
to pick up your kids or similar important
things, but the police aren’t inclined,
nor required to give you a phone call?
In these cases, the police will typically
take care of it, depending on what specifically
you need of them.
Even if you do play-nice, they may also not
allow you to use the phone if they believe
you may communicate with someone outside to
dispose of evidence or something of this nature.
For this reason, in some departments, they
may simply have a policy of always being the
go-between no matter what.
So no phone calls for you in these cases.
This, of course, leaves massive room for interpretation
for people on both sides of the law and, since
the police are only human beings, mistakes
can and will be made.
So, bottom line, once arrested, you have many
rights that you’re free to exercise; making
a phone call isn’t (usually) one of them.
Regardless of what Hollywood has told you,
yelling at an officer, “Where’s my f*****g
phone-call” is likely going to end with
you not getting one in many states.
However, if you call someone and they accidentally
hang up, an officer isn’t going to gleefully
tell you, “That was your one and only phone-call!
You’re now stuck in prison forever! *cackles
madly*” They’ll probably just let you
re-dial so they can finish processing you
and go about their other duties, or if their
shift is up, go home.
While there are certainly bad-eggs in every
profession (usually highly publicized in the
case of police), contrary to what is often
perceived because of these high profile screw-ups,
most police officers are just normal people
doing their jobs as outlined by the law and
aren’t going to go out of their way to mess
with your life.
Beyond any moral or legal issues, doing that
would typically just result in more paperwork
for them to do.
While most (including me) are happy to use
“prison” and “jail” interchangeably.
Prison and jail are technically not the same
thing.
In the U.S., jail is run by county sheriff’s
offices, while prison is run by the Prisons
and Corrections office of each state.
In Canada, jail is run by the provincial government,
while prison is run by the federal government.
You might also be wondering about phone rights
after being convicted.
The rules here also vary from state to state,
but in general there are allotted times where
prisoners will have access to a phone.
But it costs… a lot.
In fact, the fees charged by prison phone
service providers were so ridiculous that
the FCC recently stepped in.
Before this, when making calls the cost could
be as high as $17 for a 15 minute phone call.
Now, even for collect calls it’s only about
$3.15 for a 15 minute conversation.
Still quite expensive by typical standards,
but much better than over $1 per minute.
As FCC Chairman Tom Wheeler stated, “This
means that many families will no longer have
to choose between talking to their loved ones
in prison and paying their utility bills.
It means that society will benefit from the
decreased rates of recidivism that family
contact brings.”
While the inmates and their families are certainly
happy about this, the companies involved are
not and some of them are currently contesting
this in court, claiming the new rates are
below their cost to maintain the networks
to the prisons.